my name is chase with image and this is
build your squad
I have $15 to build my ultimate squad
with all-time Chiefs and 49ers needs
alright this is top man this is tough my
guy - Oh bro he's a bad man Oh Jerry I
see something but good guys are a little
expensive right I can't go for that I'm
gonna I'm gonna pick my value picks
first Patrick's kind of a value at 3
though I I feel like you did a little
bit of disrespect that guy's easy to
play tomba holy man his pastor humility
it is a peace no-brainer that that's
disrespectful a problem Len Dawson
low-key looks like the dude controlling
the Chocolate Factory I think I want to
see mine eatable my team like this
without reason alone that dude he's got
the golden ticket from he's got the
golden ticket we're sending him the
hollow let's go
as he 4 bucks up I need Co my spyro
juice 3 6
[Music]
weird all the guys see that that's the
thing is that like guys as a third round
traffic myself I you know I've always
kind of had a chip in my shoulder
you guys down here I'm worried that if
I'm gonna take these guys for $5.00
that's gonna go right to their head I'm
gonna go for the grit that's why I got
my guy laying down here I got to pick up
my guy twice two dollars in him honestly
like for me like like I'm gonna have to
incorporate a lot of trick plays in my
offense I think the question with what
we got here so we got five minutes quad
I think we're gonna do some some really
trick stuff I'm gonna have to go man
Alex Smith Serbian we're gonna top it
off to quarterback action never seen it
coming they won't know how to expect it
double quarterback passes let's go let's
go Hail Marys and then the rest of the
money
it could uh you know blow it I don't
care it's all now I'm out